is especially dangerous with the white
Pieces Just great opening preparation
for someone so young it's rare to
achieve such a kind of dynamic kind of
bulletproof opening repertoire but he
has that and Magnus starting in
provocative fashion he's gone for the
modern defense and uh we've seen him
employ this before yesterday with
success Magnus Carlson Prague has
clearly come prepared why it's h-born
marching forward to Simon you must be
loving this right now
well the last move is a surprise
um actually I mean I I love as you know
pushing the H Pawn and uh
um normally though you prepare this move
first by uh by defending that square and
I've actually played this position as
white and black
um I normally played it as white in
Blitz Games there's a bit of a punt
um but very interesting idea I mean the
critical we can maybe show the critical
line here I think because there's only
one move that really you can play I
think and that would be Knight takes
Pawn let's keep an eye as well on
magnus's reaction he looked so
devastated after this move was played
looks so Disturbed so let's keep an eye
on the player's cameras and let's jump
in it's a very interesting idea in a
chessboard course that I did along with
Richard Palace so that here you go G4
um okay wow he's actually given up the
exchange what an absolute Maniac so
that's all I'm going to say prag prag
wants to kill me he's your hero
this is this is Extreme chess and mean
he's given up the exchange so early and
he's going straight for the attack I
mean it's obviously incredibly dangerous
the knights coming in The Bishop's
coming it's like it's like old romantic
19th century chess 18th century chess
even so wow I mean he's obviously
prepared it as well you know with the
speed he's moving at the same time this
is how to beat the best players in the
world right just show them zero respect
just attack them and not only has
sacrificed material as you mentioned but
he's actually the evaluation bar loves
White's position yeah and that's rare
the computer normally is very skeptical
unless there's a forcing variation but
uh Magnus caught by a surprise just
pushing a pawn forward one square maybe
he wants to use his Queen just to defend
the pawn next to it this is the Target
right this is the weakness
I'd be interested know if this has been
played before I mean I've been playing
before and the whole idea of h4h5 is
very common isn't it you're Vancouver
who's who's actually played it so um
okay so we have a game between uh
um Ganguly against uh oh karthikian and
that ended in a win for white
okay so two very strong Indian Grand
Masters there maybe that's inspired a
prague's choice maybe Prague is aware of
that game and uh here I mean so many
tempting moves white can Castle
queenside
um just bring putting the king to safety
tucking it away in the corner and then
bringing the Rook into the game uh White
could also just bring a night out
getting ready to kind of come forward
and attack this weakness it's also
slightly tempting for white to at some
point bring his Bishop to attack the
black queen maybe you wait for that
Queen to move before you jump in here
but uh yeah I mean plenty of choices
here and uh black is going to be on the
defense it's actually quite a long-term
sacrifice Black's king is not going to
find safety for at least another five
six moves
yeah but it's like you said David this
is the way you've got to play against
the world champion I mean uh Magnus has
got got the best understanding of slow
slow positional games out of anyone
probably has ever played chess so you've
got to just try to destroy him you know
try to kill him before he can get out of
bed and that's exactly what prague's
doing I really like the sacrifice I mean
I haven't studied it before but the more
I'm looking at it it's just so easy to
play like say all those moves you
suggested they would uh make a lot of
sense even pushing a port in the center
you know stopping you know get allowing
a knight to come into that square
stopping a queen coming over the
defender he's actually gone for this one
straight away
um and this is you know it's looking
really scary but you are the exchange up
of course yeah you are the exchange up
as black you just need to survive the
next few moves and that's not a
guarantee uh as you mentioned Simon if
black is too slow
um I mean Black's natural move maybe
bringing the night out but now there are
threats serious threats attacking the
queen
you can't block really I mean if you
move your queen the White Knight might
jump in it might start coming into this
dream Square
it's uh really dangerous already you
might just Castle Queen side you might
just say okay how are you ever gonna get
the black king to safety the black king
will never find safety on this flank and
it's actually cut off so it can't Castle
through track onto the other side of the
board
there's one conclusion I've drawn from
that don't allow that Bishop to that
square
it looked too scary
yeah we yeah it means you have to take a
time out to stop this
but then if you take a turnout push your
Pawn to the square to prevent white from
using it then you've lost even further
time and white will definitely Castle
Queen side now and
maybe it's still playable it's still
hard to break through for white but I
know Simon all of your uh creative
juices are flowing right now
remember assignment show us what you can
do
any any or any old any old iron you know
just just literally get the pieces out
aim it at your opponents King check mate
that's all you need to do right maybe
you go D5 the right moment blow that
open as well you know you could really
enjoy this position and I find this
quite stressful I think it's because I'm
like such a cautious person you find you
stressful from white or yeah because
it's like if you know you make a mess of
it that's it I love these positions it's
like you know you just literally go
towards your opponent's king and you
don't have to think about anything else
there's no subtlety it's like home in
and Destroy so uh the stranger the
different different person you know
different uh ways looking at the game is
what makes it so so exciting though as
well you know because I often over press
and these kind of things
so yeah it's different styles I guess
and this is one style that Magnus hates
playing against I just remember when I
played him we were both 18 years old and
in the taxi after the game he was saying
oh I just hate it when they start
attacking me from the beginning when
they showed me no respect wow and uh I
mean I've never done that against him
I'm not brave enough to attack but uh
not in this this manner as uh kind of
just so direct but uh things if you play
this opening as black uh it's one of the
it's probably the riskiest opening you
can play as black the perk uh you're
going for incredibly sharp
counter-attacking game you must expect
this kind of thing and I think you could
see in his body language as soon as
Prague pushed Harry up to that square he
was uncomfortable you know he was like
oh I've allowed this you know so he
really and his body language is you know
all it just doesn't seem like he's
enjoying us at all I mean would anyone
join his position with the black Pieces
Just defending against all the whites
pieces coming in I mean not unless
you've prepared it really deeply with a
computer and you can guarantee you'll
survive the next five six moves there's
no guarantee here for black we just
showed one variation that was very scary
White's Bishop coming forward but that's
probably one of multiple variations uh
possible ideas that Prague has in the
next few moves and look how comfortable
Prague is right now he's okay he's
starting his typical rocking getting the
energy pumping but Magnus we saw it
immediately as you mentioned Simon but
also leaning back he's now heading hands
could we be seeing another Victory by
the young Indian over Magnus
beats him so often doesn't it he's won
four individual games in the tour how he
beat him in the uh yeah yeah in the
final of Miami in the final round yeah
recently one on demand as well I have
three three wins for Prague
maybe it's three yeah three two draws
five uh wins four minus the season yeah
yeah could this be game number four win
number four for prank I mean Magnus is
going to be Front Page News around the
world for all the wrong reasons losing
you know against Prague in India in
Norway you've already mentioned it's the
whole incident it's it's gonna be don't
don't read the papers tomorrow I'd
suggest to Magnus I mean if he loses
this game and I can just see him getting
crushed here I mean uh okay he's trying
to keep the position closed and take
away a square for the white knight uh
that makes a lot of sense but it's now
White's move can why increase the
pressure here why he just castles he
doesn't care about being exchanged out
no look at the evaluation bar it thinks
that white is just winning wow um I mean
still material down remember white is
down a rook for a night in a pawn but
the attack matches must just be kind of
long term it must just be that dangerous
ferocious
black king I just don't see it getting
to safety anytime soon
doesn't look that bad I mean if you
throw the Knight towards Black's King
and try to Castle you know where you're
safe as black I mean maybe that's the
problem Simon you can't get your king to
safety yeah it's I guess so because you
actually can't put the knight in front
of the queen what am I talking about
that's a horrendous move to play maybe
the worst move on the board whoops yes
you just get your queen trapped so oh
dear yeah so there's a little bit of
danger well Magnus has played you say
when you're getting attacked don't open
up your king so what's he done he's open
up his King so very risky move that as
well but he's got it I guess he's got to
take risks yeah I mean that I guess he's
banking on the fact that after a capture
he's solid enough I mean it looks shaky
uh actually here white tonight can maybe
start jumping in although black and
about survive Bishop takes porn plugging
all the holes looks very very scary it
comes out and whoa yeah we could go 10
News deep there but we won't uh we'll
wait to see what uh Prague comes up with
but it would be very tempting right just
capture this Pawn open up the white Rook
open up lines even further and the
reason this was working uh this last
variation is because this Pawn cannot
really take the White Knight it is
pinned after all yeah if the white
knight jumps into if the white knight
gets into this Square it's just game
over
um it's very natural to open a position
have planned I mean you're just giving a
pawn back actually now it's level
material and you're getting attacked
every piece is asleep basically
um I mean this bishop is like uh come on
wake up the rest of you uh you forgot to
set your alarm clock yeah maybe he's got
Simon's idea in mind that now the night
can develop
in front of the
Queen's looking at this oh yeah
okay forget that one that's just too
dangerous but yeah Prague has said yeah
I will welcome that opening and now the
bishop has developed that that's a much
better move yeah yeah but it's white to
move and
just looks like there's so many
dangerous ideas here I mean
developing can't be bad bringing the
Knight around I mean there's there's
many tenses it's just very easy to play
these positions when you're attacking
because again you just look at your
opponent's king move pieces towards it
um and materialistically I mean okay I
mean he's only one point down let's
remember now it was it was I remember
bronstein David bronstein one of the
strongest players known to become world
champion he was doing a lecturize that
and he basically said he loved the
king's Gambit going back to the Romantic
days and he said that you know giving up
the exchange at the start of the game is
a great idea because minor pieces
Knights and Bishops are better than
Rooks at the start of the game it's only
in the ending or late middle game where
the Rooks become more powerful Knights
and Bishops and he made this point time
and time again
um in some brilliant games in the king's
Gambit uh that you know minor pieces are
better than Rooks look at the Rooks the
Rooks are not going to get in the game
and uh White's Knights can so you've got
to survive that damn that danger here
for black somehow
yeah Magnus I think at this point he's
just with his last couple of moves he's
just hoping he's playing moves that he
think it's uh kind of helped long term
but he's just hoping there's nothing
short-term to crash through for Prague
and for Prague I guess the biggest
Pitfall is that he gets carried away
calculating kind of ideas trying to
force the win immediately uh when he
should I think as you mentioned uh Simon
just keep things simple develop develop
pieces white does have a couple of
pieces that haven't moved either so
bring those into the battle yeah I mean
I was thinking of like stupid moves as
you can easily get carried away here but
don't take the pawn with a rook Simon
just calm down and okay he's played a
more positional approach right I mean it
blocked in the bishop he's blocked in
the bishop but he's keeping his strong
pawn and Center on
I don't know I mean I'm not sure I like
that so much because it it it takes a
bit of time but it still still looks
very good according to computer yeah
Me Maybe you know the key is actually
just to
keep the black king Stuck in the Middle
because you know I'm living by magnus's
rules the queen is threatening to come
to to step in front of the square in
front of the king and then the king will
just hide away to safety
yeah maybe you just try to blow the
position open with F5 I mean pushing
that pawn you've moved again the Knight
can also develop Menders
I mean it's oh this looks horrible it's
very I mean you know why not try a chat
mate it's quite fun give it giving it a
go have fun I guess it could backfire
could backfire here because Pawn will
drop I'm not sure yeah he chooses I like
this one as well Simon in a Blitz game
you play this and you just Checkmate and
you win this is much more sensible get
the Firepower in first right see yeah
bring the knight in and ideas of this
one and Ivanka you mentioned if the
black queen moves yeah
then uh black is one move away from
castling one move away from safety
um several ideas here for white but
among them maybe Simon's idea again well
hello I might take that point by Rook
now because I just can't resist it just
because it might be rubbish but I gotta
do it maybe you could kind of I I think
this is a bit smelly for black right it
looks a bit scary if black yeah I mean
the other night's coming in and yeah if
you go here there's a family Fork uh
hitting everything and yeah if you as
you mentioned if you go back to square
one then
maybe how do you survive Checkmate
threatened your Bishop is coming in to
attack that script I mean but the beauty
of defensive chess is that you sometimes
don't need to take the material that's
been offered yeah
what is a rook down so yeah it's true it
might not work this might not work it's
just fun looking at these games because
you rarely see this kind of romantic
old-school kind of way of playing not
since uh 1890 exactly a game like this
one yeah a long time before these guys
are around especially prank right yeah
so this definitely is a battle of
generations
yeah and uh the Young Generation I think
the reason they're so successful is they
are just fearless and they haven't
learned that fear yet and especially
while they're young they're being taught
to keep attacking these top players when
I was younger it was like no I just
learned to draw against them first just
learn to survive learn to
um kind of play positional chess against
these top guys fight them in that regard
but why not attack them uh why not go
for the king and that's exactly what
Prague is doing
really dangerous for Magnus right now I
mean this variation just looks almost
winning uh the one that Simon pointed
out just pushing this Pawn forward
breaking open further lines hitting the
queen
among other ideas uh lazy also mentioned
Rook takes born looks very strong
maybe you have to bring the Queen the
other way David I mean uh I love the
idea of trying to Castle the black king
right you're not going to Castle King's
side you have to go the long way where
the queen is you have to get the queen
out the way let's bring the black queen
all the way towards as you say there
David why can't you go kingside it's too
open there you need your Pawns in front
your king they're like your bodyguards
and there's a Target you always look for
a square that you can attack in your
opponent's camp and there's a way here
that white can easily bring a bishop in
threatening Checkmate in one move there
because black doesn't have a pawn in
front of the king so that's why going
the other way it's a bit more blocked
over there and you want to put your King
on the side where your opponent can't
get through to it with his pieces it
doesn't look more blocked to me but uh
there's no Bishop so you can get through
on that side so it's about the enemy
pieces right so where where's White's
kind of attacking potential it's the
queen it's the Knight there's a few
other pieces at least if you Castle on
the other side the queen is far away the
White Queen is going to be the one doing
the check mating so uh just run away as
far as possible from her She's the One
chasing you you might as well uh get a
head start in the race okay so that's a
rule for everyone if you do Castle after
move 12 which is that is the ground
rules try to Castle before move 12 but
if it's after and the queen is in the
game try to look out for her and Castle
the other way yeah just don't Castle
into the eye of the storm don't Castle
Into the Fire
um yeah here magnus's move is almost
automatic and Prague will try and find a
way to make that less attractive okay
yeah
quite funny one of the things that I
tell myself or actually I tell my
students who are very very young and I
say talk to your pieces yeah doesn't
actually have a conversation with them
so if the king did go to the into the
eye of the storm and the King was like
Hey I need help which one of the pieces
are going to help and if you know if you
actually talk to your pieces the nights
would go like oh no don't ask me yeah
Bishop the dark Square Bishop nope you
forget it I ain't involved you and I
give them all like little voice okay
this is this is why maybe I'm suited to
teaching like five-year-olds but yeah we
have a lot of fun
have they ever done that in a tournament
they sort of said yeah hello um right
where are you going now and like uh you
know just like eventually you know
tweaking throughout the games yesterday
yeah yeah that's true I just I just
think that in the analysis portion you
know when you're by yourself or you're
teaching someone you should make it as
fun as possible and especially if you're
engaging with young children you know
you need to you need to activate the
drama the storytelling because otherwise
it can be just a bit boring yeah and uh
I I well maybe that just kind of
reflects on me but I I tried to do that
it reminds me of again Top Gun we keep
singing welcome to the dangerous Zone
and I I watched the Top Gun a few nights
ago and I I could see that Tom Cruise
Fox to his played all the time oh he
does he does it did you see the new one
let's see the new one oh I liked it it
was good I saw it I saw it on the cinema
last time I was over here actually so uh
in Norway yeah very good film I thought
yeah talk to you talk to your plane talk
to your car off talk to whatever you're
doing in life yeah just talk to it so
you know it makes everything a lot more
fun just don't let people see that
you're talking yeah yes inanimate
objects they might send you to the uh
yes some advice a few many many years
ago they used to call Prince Charles or
King Charles as is now no uh just fruity
because he used to talk to plants oh but
then they did an experiment they had
like two plants they had the exact same
conditions now okay by experiment I mean
this is like social media shared in a
video so you know who knows how correct
it was and one of these plants they
abused and the other plants that they
told it complements and the one which
receives the compliments thrived and the
poor one that was like told all these
insults just like looked really sad oh
so they said you know you should be
talking and complimenting and you notice
a lot of they say that with uh you know
grapevines a lot of grapevines they play
classical music and the the vines that
are growing near the speakers have
bigger great you know so uh it's true
it's true it's true must be true so uh
if you're trying to grow vegetables you
know or anything just you know just talk
to them sing to them yeah get some
classical music on the go you know if
you want some Big Melons or whatever you
want then just you know get to get the
music going through them yeah if you
talk to your pieces they'll be infused
with energy and they'll do the
checkmating for you exactly you don't
even need to do anything you're just
like hello my little friend you're
having a you'd look lovely there today
beautiful piece you are
but then when they get captured they'll
feel so sad it's true if you could say
good job good job
and they're talking about a piece that
could get captured wow there's a Pawn on
F7 that is up for grabs at least Magnus
is Castle right I mean like I think no
matter what the situation you just had
to get his King over there and uh I I
I'd be feeling a bit more comfortable
actually if I was him I mean you're not
going to get checkmated now right you
mean you might lose some other way but
your king is relatively safe
for the time being wow and uh we've been
talking about Prague having a big attack
a winning attack okay he does play the
best move I was about to say stockfish
does say on our screens in front of us
uh that one move is significantly better
than the others every other move would
have given black an advantage but Prague
finds it we've called that Prague style
before he's uh he's very good at finding
uh those moves when they're far better
than the others and he does take this
Pawn with the queen some viewers at home
might be wondering what would have
happened if he had played an alternative
so in this position he took the pawn
with his Queen very sensible the best
move on the board if you're taken with
the Knight then maybe he would have
walked into a pin the black Bishop would
have stepped back pinning the White
Knight to the White Queen this is
awkward in itself but there's also a
secondary threat now because the black
Rook has opened up there are ideas of
the pawn pushing forward so for example
see what makes a move the pawn will step
forward with a double attack hitting the
Knight hitting the bishop and black is
doing very very well also threats of The
Rook just winning this pinned Knight so
okay prag of course spotted that one not
the most uh disguised idea by Magnus if
black didn't have that Bishop Retreat he
would have been suffering so now after
quick explore and what do you think guys
uh two big threats on the board Queen
takes bishop and Knight takes Pawn
how does black defend against both of
them I mean if the Black Santa
disappears then you know it's going to
be just a house of cards right I think
and Black's Position will crumble uh you
know I say it's a bit better for black
than it was because black was getting
[ __ ] mated before and if anyone can put
up a defense it's Magnus but
positionally now it looks pretty
horrendous right
um I mean aren't you winning that pawn
by force or is there any anything that
black can do here well I I accidentally
looked at the computer analysis
um
black does have a special move
special move uh yeah and uh it's out of
the yeah just push that pawn forward and
I guess the logic is that once the
captures say the bishop captures the
pawn and Knight takes Bishop I'm
presuming
and then if Rook takes
then the queen can actually capture no
the Queen corn capture so this was me
that would be a big feeling you don't
want to be doing that you should walk
into a pin yeah I haven't seen further
than this David I just know that D4 is
the best move yeah I mean I'm trying to
work it out now what the best move
Bishop takes porn I think is is the way
to play this bishop takes one yeah then
Rook f8 afterwards oh my God that's
awesome I love spotted Bishop takes porn
and a skewer at the end you skewer the
White Queen and the white Bishop uh once
the White Queen moves out the way this
is a check and the table's turn
so yeah this is the kind of thing that
can go wrong right if you're not careful
so it's uh yeah I mean if he he's got to
find this move though right I guess he's
got to do a counter attack here
otherwise otherwise this is really
tricky yeah so uh this Pawn push we
think might be the only way for black to
survive
um if you just move this bishop this
attacked piece maybe this is the other
thing Magnus is calculating the first
move that came to my mind okay my piece
is attacked let's move it if white takes
this Pawn okay he does find the best
move of course then Knight takes Pawn
would have been very complicated but uh
Magnus okay he does decide it's time to
counter attack no more passive play
and evaluation bar still thinks White's
doing well but that variation we showed
things were turning so Prague has to be
very careful what is his move here you
could make an argument for just taking
this bishop off the board
for example
oh I don't know actually black will
capture this Knight and suddenly the
white king
in a bit of trouble
oh it's incredibly sharp it is yeah I
mean it's really hard to work out now
what's happening even though it's you
know when the computer's there okay it's
simple but uh simple to say who's better
but
if you're playing this position I mean
Magnus is going to be feeling a lot more
confident now his King's safe he's got
some counter-attacking chances
so what would you actually play I mean
do you do you tape once and then take
the bishop do you I don't know maybe
this is a safe option at least White's
King is safe for now but doesn't look
very good though does it but then you
can actually go Queen takes pawn and
yeah all together I guess the White
Knight will jump into this Square it's
still very complicated at least here
White's King is safer than it was in the
other uh variations we showed it's just
about the comparison of Kings but black
is still ahead of material slightly and
uh Rook four Rook for a minor piece
yeah if we go back to the composition
everything's hanging this black Bishop
is on uh it's loose uh this is a double
attack
a lot of calculations to be done both
plays around five minutes
we could see a turnaround despite being
in control
yeah and that last line is a crazy thing
you get three pieces for the queen you
don't have to Rook f8 you've got Rook
takes D7 right uh oh in this uh okay
this issue just just for a laugh so um
we'll show what's going through the
Beautiful Mind of Ginger
Bishop takes
this one right yeah yeah and we saw this
position earlier we might be headed in
that direction potentially
um so the skewer are now Rook takes
Bishop yeah giving up the White Queen
but after a capture on this Square
I guess the Knight takes and plants
itself yeah three pieces for a queen oh
Rook takes F7 immediately was also the
other option I guess so okay this hasn't
happened but yeah okay this is I mean
crazy we can forgive uh Prague for not
going for this queen against three minor
pieces
um yeah who knows who's better here yeah
uh computer would probably laugh at us
but uh Prague deciding to go for the
safe option it often laughs at me that's
the problem far far too often too yeah I
think the cool variation though yeah if
an adult squares are too weak in that
one and uh he's gone for this queen
takes Bishop but we didn't think
that Magnus was in serious trouble now
did we um he's getting some coordination
uh with his pieces and he seems to be
over the worse uh I would have fought
here at least this Queen's struggling
for squares as well she's only got two
safe squares okay she chooses this one
there were two options
yeah suddenly it feels like Black's
coordinating Black's Knight is nicely
placed Black's Rook at some point will
come into the action but I can take this
Pawn at will whenever he wants
yeah it's in the balance yeah Magnus has
uh survived and it was all about
survival that's I think the key in chess
when you're defending just focus on one
thing you can counter-attack later
and okay he hits the White Queen
where will she go
like this uh strategy from Magnus you
know just kick the queen around you know
get her away from the black king and
that in turn releases the light Square
Bishop which can open up the center line
um excellent play by the world champion
of course even saying it's slightly
turning in magnus's favor can he win
this game definitely I mean it's it's
all about momentum interest as well
sometimes we see a swing from completely
winning from White for white to equal
and then that just means as one of the
players you sense it you know you were
struggling suddenly you have chances
suddenly pieces of falling on good
squares uh your opponent meanwhile will
be like oh I missed chances something
went wrong psychologically it can be
hard to recover
Prague also slightly lower on the clock
under four minutes against magnus's five
yeah anything possible in this one
should we have a vote who would you pick
I I go Magnus that because it's just the
way the game's changed I mean he's got
over this horrible opening uh which
we're getting so excited about he's
castled he's attacking now
um he is the exchange up so I I'm all in
uh magnus's side in this position here
just uh I like white spawn structure
yeah Levar is now going up to 0.7 for
Magnus Carlsen in this battle of
generation 17 year old Prague against uh
30 what is it one year old Magnus
Carlsen another battle between
Generations the youngest versus the
oldest player in the tournament 15 year
old Christopher you against the 54 year
old
I can see the bar is very much in favor
of Boris gelfund in that game so maybe
the older generation is winning that
battle in the battle between our true
polish players Duda against voice is
looking very good for voita check we do
already have one result a draw between
Iman Sarge and Arjun eregaisi as that
means is still on top of the table if we
do have a winner in this game then that
player will join Eric icy on 17 points
heading into day three out of four days
in the preliminaries tomorrow
and is a win the most likely result in
this game if it is Prague or if it is
Magnus uh yeah I mean even if the
computer says zero point something I
just don't see how this position is
going to be a draw it's just so wild so
imbalanced uh not just in terms of
material but also Pawn structure King
safety it's wild so a draw I think the
least likely of the three results there
and okay the Black Knight jumps in this
looks like maybe the most natural move
in the position attacking the white Rook
but of course the computer dislikes it
yeah so that's how hard it is for humans
to keep up with computers
why why could a computer dislike this
move
ment
it looks so natural right it does right
you know maybe the only thing that I can
think of is that the Rook isn't big in a
move and attack the night and the night
has to take a decision
[Music]
yeah
so crazy okay there is a crazy one who
Prague has played it well I I was
thinking about it because you know only
because of the bar you know told us
there was something there you have to
that's when that's when cheating would
help right yeah because if you're new in
that situation the bars change you'd
look for something a bit outrageous so
you your eyes would be drawn to this
kind of move I don't know why it works
it just you know okay wow two exchanges
down yeah what is the count here black
has two Rooks in return white has a
knight a bishop and
coupons I mean someone did some nuts for
me please it's been too long a day but
it's a crazy material imbalance and
I mean the white king looks like it's
about to get checkmated the black Brooks
like look like they're about to just get
chopped off the board Black Knight looks
beautiful how did Prague evaluate this I
mean maybe he thought there was no other
option
um that's the that's the way often top
chess players find the best move every
time it's just process of elimination
moving The Rook to a safe Square didn't
work didn't look good so you have to
sacrifice and just hope for the best
but uh this one is still anyone's game
and I have a feeling both players think
they have the advantage right now
an imbalance like this where both sides
have cut like this weird material
combination and both sides kings are
Under Fire just incredible stuff I would
just move the Rook of Iowa Magnus and uh
you know black also has some tricks up
their sleeve like the move that I would
be planning and plotting would be to
actually move the Knight and put it on
the D1 Square
wow okay yeah um yeah we can show this
oh wow wow what a move
it's all going crazy I love that move
that's such a cool move yeah the problem
is I'm not sure what's going to happen
so this bishop is attacked if the bishop
moves then uh yeah it will cover the
square
um yeah I mean if the bishop doesn't
move then you'll move your idea Ivanka
we should explain is to jump in you kick
the White Knight away and uh yeah once
the king runs it's gonna be Checkmate
but yeah unfortunately as you point out
yeah
Queen takes queen or it takes and that
crank trackmate but there are ideas
against the white king I think that's
the point right yeah uh so in the
current position the bishop is attacked
and if it moves still some ideas maybe
against the white king if it doesn't
move he'll just get chopped off the
board again how does the computer think
it's just like such a small Advantage
for either side it looks like someone
should be winning
okay the bishop does move
and uh very sensible yeah I mean White's
pieces are looking good and now Magnus
is trying to swap off right
similar ideas to what Ivanka has in mind
potentially the White Knight capturing
the Black Knight it wouldn't end a
Checkmate because this check can be
blocked by the White Queen
but I mean what a material imbalance
we'll get in that end game if the Queens
disappear but uh yeah ideally Prague I
guess doesn't really want to trade off
uh his defensive Knight
after Knight takes night for example
instead of this check black could also
just take back and still two Rooks
against two minor pieces you've got to
favor the two Rooks somehow
um really really complicated what a game
these two just entertaining I mean
strong strong players and entertaining
they they always have great games don't
they I mean every every time these two
play uh is always extremely extremely
entertaining and sharp stuff so yeah as
this game is this is a brilliant game
yeah I mean often we see two strong
players just neutralizing each other
just playing a very sensible kind of
solid game and it's just a draw but uh
these two
bring out the best in each other this
could be a rivalry for the next 10 10 20
years I just saw that someone was
worried about my computer after the
coffee's built on it I'd just like to
clarify it's not my computer it's oh yes
if steam starts coming up
oh
meanwhile the Queens did leave the boat
we showed that variation where Black's
Queen jumped in with a check white came
back to block
and uh right now again material count
black has two Rooks with ten white has a
knight a bishop and
is it four points it is four points so
night Bishop before that's also worth
ten wow okay yeah this so it's equal
it's enough counting for me today we
need that guy back again on this game I
think but uh this position is just crazy
because you have to let go of some pawns
and okay he's decided to let go of the
G2 Pawn but the white king is now going
to get mobilized
attacks from Brooks and then you know
White's plan is so straightforward you
know just push those past pawns to their
destination
it looks dangerous I would be terrified
I mean maybe yeah I mean I mean is
Prague winning this a computer seems to
think so evaluation bars are really
woken up and uh I love this last idea
just giving away one Pawn just not even
caring that black syrup came and took
upon but the white king is going to join
as an attack if as an attacking piece in
the same game it's similar to what Magna
showed against Iranian active Kings
they're just an extra piece and okay the
BlackRock moves
wow is this Rook getting trapped maybe
wow I've got to be really careful where
you go with this evaluation bar doesn't
doesn't like it but these are two very
human players playing a great game
that Rook does have two safe squares I
was gonna say either you come across on
a dark square or you go back up the
board sit on a dark Square you don't
want to get hit by White's Bishop
now the path is cleared for those two
white Pawns in the center
it's like hard this game is to work out
isn't it I mean so hard I mean it's kind
of game where it's probably easier if
you turn off the compute evaluation
because it changes so much because it's
so Dynamic and either side could win
this even though it says Prague is well
in charge I mean I guess his pawns are
just very scarier simply those pawns are
going to roll and the Knight and Bishop
work very well together the Rooks are
disconnected at the same time
um also just mentioning Advantage it
doesn't seem to be having a great day
today I hope he I hope he comes back
into the mix Jackie I want to I want to
see him qualifying still we're Chucky
fans here so yeah we'll see you tomorrow
about that yeah
uh maybe we can jump in to explain why
white probably has the advantage here
um just dropping back with a knight
check okay wow I was I was thinking yeah
black would love to just eliminate one
of these pieces but uh yeah now suddenly
the white porn structure is broken up
the black king is going to take this guy
in Simon you made a sound there no I I
think this is now you know if anyone's
gonna win this it'll be blackmail again
it's changed again probably a draw but
yeah you've lost all your advantage by
allowing that countersack white needed
to keep the Knight intact maybe just
Retreat it to this Square keep these two
Pawns in your pocket for later it's
Black's dream to get rid of his Rook for
your knight and two pawns and uh if we
catch up with the current situation big
mistake here from Prague strategically
just dropping his Knight back allowing
this uh transition uh suddenly if in the
current position yeah it looks like a
draw
um simply the black with the white
Bishop will hold everything together
defend the pawns but blackbrook is
superior
in general so can white actually think
about winning this game you know after
all the as you've highlighted the king
can run in grab some pawns I mean I
think the owners are still on black to
defend this one yeah I'm a bit surprised
magnus's last moves uh I mean here he
had the white king cut off why not just
defend the Rook look it's body language
David I mean he just uh you can see that
I think he's also he just did some sort
of uh very upsetting you know I've
messed it up again kind of thing there
so you're right yeah why has he done
this yeah if he just protects the Rook
with the pawn the white king cannot
break through towards those black pawns
but uh he moved the Rook trying to keep
the king cut off but the cutoff is
broken and this barrier is no longer
existent and uh yeah oh sorry me and my
Harris the king is coming in
wow Magnus has played a really weird
move this last one dropping The Rook
back the whole idea I guess is that if
the king marches forward the black king
will also step out the way and the king
is cut off on this line
but yeah maybe you're right Ivanka maybe
white is the one hoping for the win
still what a crazy game
it's a great game we are definitely
following the action in this game but
we're also joined by a player who is
finished for the day Anish giri hey
congratulations with the win in your
final game
hi hi thank you thank you what has today
been like Ganesh
you want my hot take on the hot matter
what is it we're gonna pretend you know
we're gonna ignore the elephant in the
room there
well you know you said it what do you
think about Magnus resigning against
Neiman are you shocked
yeah I mean The Show Must Go On yeah
um it reminds me of um
yeah I mean it's like when you play
Pokemon on the first because I saw you
play smoker so you you pull up on the
first then it comes you know another
card you keep laughing and another card
and you keep laughing but um yeah I mean
um it looks like uh you know it's
clearly insinuating something but uh you
know until you catch someone you cannot
um
you cannot do anything so
it's just it just looks very odd now I
mean clearly you know it all makes sense
if uh supposedly Hans is cheating and he
doesn't want to play him but um if he
doesn't then it is really um very wrong
so I don't know we have to see I mean
again everybody is expecting some kind
of Big Rapids from the head with Magnus
but he just doesn't want to play hands
it seems and it's quite quite
interesting that the game after that he
played so well I was thinking you know
like you might be disturbed but he was
just undeserved really a special human
being for sure
are you like the rest of the the Chess
World basically calling for Magnus to
explain this and uh maybe come with some
evidence against Hans
but I think it's pretty clear that um
he doesn't have um he doesn't have it
um
because if he had there would be no need
to do that it's pretty clear to me
um that he is convinced or near
convinced that uh that is the case uh
based on the evidence that already is
Publix it just let me just made the book
took that call and uh that's a big
problem you know playing people who have
been banned and especially who have been
who have admitted to cheat online before
because you lose trust in these people
and that is a major major problem
also insulinating of cheating is a big
problem so all of these things are they
have to be somehow resolved
and I mean my word of advice for young
players especially The Talented ones I
mean
there's so much damage you do to
yourself when you cheat online you know
in some small events because these
things they stick and then afterwards
the big boys they they don't trust you
anymore you know and that's just that's
uh that's not good so yeah I mean
definitely you know with this drama like
every time you need some new information
to keep the drama going but today you
know we just think we'll definitely keep
perspiring for a while just yeah crazy
great stuff going on and it's not clear
how it will end because as we see like
there is no I don't think Magnus has any
anything more than what's there I mean
there is the repeated cheating online
there is the
the I mean slightly uh weird
character that uh Hans is portraying but
you know I mean yeah just the fact that
all that that doesn't mean that he
cheats uh all the time or doesn't mean
that he cheats over the board or it's
just very very confusing
um oh yeah yeah not much too bad really
well and you play Hans name on tomorrow
in around 10 and each are you
uncomfortable playing him
let me be very Frank
um because I
um I knew about all this everybody knew
about all the stuff about online
cheating and we know about online
cheating by multiple other players well
okay uh because these things they just
uh leaked and uh I mean these are not
the top players but the young players
who have been banned on various websites
um I so I always thought the
responsibility that house is cheating
but looking at my own games
um I had a conviction that he never did
that against me because he usually plays
very badly but so either way um yeah
there are swing levels um level swings
in his play and uh that might very well
do with the fact that he's very young
there are also many uh level swings uh
with everyone but in particular with the
young players because they know some
positions better they know some position
less they looked at some lines they
didn't look at some others they studied
some Catalan lines you know uh didn't
look some I don't know antibi lens so um
yeah I'm eager to play hands I've done
very well against him before he plays
very forward against me so I'm not uh
concerned but of course he he seems to
be improving his rating is rising
whatever the reason is whether he's uh
just legit very strong or um what uh
Mario is trying to insimiate but either
way it is of course an exciting game it
can be dangerous as well so I'm looking
forward I mean whenever I play I always
push these thoughts away and I heard
that Magnus said the same in some
interview but I don't know what happened
to him like whenever you play you have
to uh just assume that the opponents
don't cheat it's like one of these
it's one of the psychological issues
that players uh uh struggle to play a
struggle and normally you don't withdraw
you just uh I mean if you can't deal
with them you'd go to therapist
and you deal with those because yeah
there are always issues and I mean I've
heard from my colleagues many people
insinuating them notice here telling
directly the suspecting other colleagues
of achieving uh it's always a thing and
I guess in other sports they have that
developing or whatever but you just have
to push these thoughts away because it's
just very disturbing you cannot play
when you think your opponent is cheating
you just kind of play you like you're
gonna play an engine you think we will
lose for sure you must push these
thoughts away and that's what I'm trying
to do and I think it's important that
everybody tries to do that yeah
very interesting hearing your thoughts
on this issue Anish we wish you best of
luck tomorrow as well in your fight to
qualify for the Knockouts thanks for
joining us thank you
very valid point from Manish giri there
if you do suspect of cheating and you
can't get that out of your head that
must be almost impossible to play in
maybe that is what's going on with
Magnus resigning against Hans Niemann
this one is it now going to be a draw
yes I'm slightly surprised Magnus went
for this last move uh giving up his Rook
for White's bishop and pawn white is a
pawn up but some calculation is needed
if the white king can make its way and
win Black's Pawn
it's a game over but Magnus knows his
endgames and there's not going to be a
way for white to win this one black
keeps the opposition like he does here
blocks off the advance of the white king
and uh we're just gonna see a Shuffle by
both Kings here no way uh no way through
this is End Game 101. King opponent game
is so tricky but if you know your stuff
you can save a lot of points
yeah this one uh it's so unfair chess
you see the most exciting game roller
coaster game they always seem to end in
drawers however and uh King versus King
did you see that Magnus just clapped
applauded Prague and we have a draw
wow that is uh so interesting Magnus
calls and I'm pregnant on that they keep
having the best fights in the mouthwater
Champions chess tour and this one went
all the way down to King versus King a
draw between the 17 year old and the
world number one Magnus Carlsen now we
are oh look at that and Applause does
that what is that about when he's
applauding I think he just loves players